damit werden aber hollywood wasser hat
vorjahr
nur zwölf minuten
murat ernsthaft herzlich willkommen und
salis welt heute hier doch was ganz
besonderes weil wir haben schon lange in
klinik ein video gemacht und derzeit
geschult natürlich werden alle seitige
gekocht hat war der könig auf der
baustelle haben die arbeiten deswegen
ist lange keine videos gegeben und heute
fangen wieder an und jetzt zu führen
begrüßen
hier erkennt ihn interpretiert ihn nie
so wichtig sind haben ist absolut
wir haben zwar wenn wir zusammen
arbeiten schon seit ja habe ja noch ein
stück höher auf jetzt so auf jeden fall
haben wir den abstand der gummi was sein
muss und wir haben lange gut
zusammengearbeitet weil du bist ja ein
risikopatient richtig ja und zwar weil
der genetischen risiko für uns alle
und deswegen war mir eigentlich die
ganze zeit richtig damit werden rottweil
corona muss ja erst antikörper gegen
dich bilden auch gegen ja ok auf jeden
fall
wir sind besorgt ich bin gesund das kann
man kann man selber will
wir sind ja bekannt für herzhafte
gerichte genau richtig moment ja auch
herzhafte kriegen wir was machen und
wird für den übrigens die nennen ist
nicht mehr müssen sie nennen es jetzt so
ein bisschen englisch denn ist das
college dass das ist dann erhöht sich
sein cooler an bord und und es werden
wären ja viele begriffe werden ja
inzwischen ein so englisch gemacht hat
sich einfach cooler an
früher hieß das ja es heißt es dort das
war influenza weil es ist ja wenn man
kriegt ja ja nein aber die influenza ist
früchte einfach nur hauptschüler ja
[Gelächter]
nichts beste freundin schon seit jahren
noch heute unseren wäre doch heute auf
den tag haben unseren 13 jahrestag ist
es ist sehr freundschaftlich die
beleidigend wir uns ein kopf- reaktionen
sind eigentlich sehr lieb gemeint kann
recht und bin ist ein guter freund von
mir weil er schlecht sieht und schlecht
hören
und deswegen sind wir gute freunde
aufhalten lassen wir machen heute eine
richtig coole holzfäller fanden das ding
heißt holzfäller panne weil machst du
mal hast du schon mal holz gefällt ja
schon gemacht die die hallen auch
geringen allerdings habe der mann soll
das gehen wieso den rippen haben auch
international zu schützen
aber ich sehe ja sowieso vor jemand
kommt und einen raum rein und müssten
temperatur messen eines plötzlichen
elektro these könnte dann ist es
natürlich wird es so feiert ich würde
das teilen auf jesus mein herz steckt
nicht in würde die these auf jeweils die
zweiten wir haben ja ganz ganz tolle
zutaten es war ganz einfache zutaten
wird ich wohl mit nicht überall bekommt
richtig reinhängen ich habe nämlich ein
ding was wir sagen jede jedes rezept
muss aus zutaten bestehen die
aufschreiben können
richtig ich habe nur an sprache
schreiben ich war als schreibender öko
steuer firma tomatenmark theo rent a.de
nrk
aber zusammen geschrieben da größer nein
das ist der fed gehöre sagte überlegen
im angst richtig wäre es gut ist dass
ich dem verein stellte schließlich doch
noch was kannst du ja aber ich hab' ich
habe das nicht gehabt um andere sagen
das ist ja andere geeinigt
auf jeden fall nicht das video die länge
ziehen wir sind schon bei minute vier
wahrscheinlich haben noch nicht mal die
leute wissen nur dass man einen
holzfäller pop machen holzfäller druck
machen wir genau deftig und das wohl
haben wir die zutaten und die zutaten
die zeichnung
das erste was sie brauchen ist 4 liter
olivenöl 4 peter molyneux hier ist
löffel olivenöl und 1000 gramm
ich würde nur testen lassen gramm also
wir brauchen olivenöl von der heide
meiner von einem olivenhain meine mutter
so heißt es also wir brauchen vier
esslöffel olivenöl von den reinen meiner
mutter was olivenhainen heißt es du bist
du bist das heißt es heide oder
heidenheim heim heim heute oliven
das ist dann eben handschrift mit hp
entweder rein und ich will auch nicht
mein kopf daran tun und dann ja mach und
viermal ziehen haben wir immer machen
bekomme ich mag sie hat vier esslöffel
olivenöl
dann haben auch 1000 gramm kinder
gulasch dann haben wir zwei zwiebeln 2
knoblauchzehen 80 gramm tomatenmark
tomatenmark eingefasst software auch die
qual wenn nach fünf jahren
dann haben wir hier so was wie wifi nur
halt türkische und türgriffe und dann
haben wir hier 4 kam champignons ist ein
kultur champignons was kultur die haben
kultur
du bist kulturlos was anderes so also
was du nicht hast ja genau kultur genau
dann haben wir hier drillinge als
kartoffeln also auf 500 g training aus
der pfalz trainings und kartoffel arten
genau 80 milliliter
ich habe vorher lieben menschen
ich bin morgens mache ich auf ist eine
wunderhübsche frau leben gelegen dann
kommt meine zwei kleinen kinder die
künftig dann und ein wunderschönes
familienleben und dann mache ich morgens
die tür auf und haben kaffee und alles
ist schön sich den form ja so und dann
die aggression im jahr habe ich mit
druck habe ich ein völlegefühl dann aber
ja das kommt auch nicht von mir das
völlegefühl ja das kannst du mir jetzt
lieber erzählt er denke ich mir warum so
dann haben wir natürlich auch noch ein
paar coole zutaten dann haben wir noch
tomaten außer dose da könnt ihr mit
tomatensoße nehmen weil man kann ja sein
dass gar keine tomaten frische vom
spender im hintergrund genau das ist ja
gar winter ist momentan aber ich sage
auch immer ja aber die werden auch
winter gerade wir wissen es nicht so
dann haben wir zwei lorbeerblätter dann
haben wir auch salz also es hat nichts
mit zigarettenrauch zu tun dann haben
wir hier
kreuzkümmel dann haben wir paprika
edelsüß und dann haben wir noch oregano
und dann haben wir noch können wir noch
mal kurz das wort hilfe
das war ja stimmt genau geschmack zu
dazu daten an sonst die gewürze darf ich
ja keine ganzen genannt das ist so würde
ich das möchte mögen und es war ein
abspecken muss mal abschmecken genau
kreuzkümmel ist für mich gehörten
einfach dazu das ist so weist die
kreuzkümmel richtig hast du schon mal
den tun wollt mal drei tage drei wochen
lang im gegen vergessen
aber ja jetzt heute beruhigt
dafür kann gut sein sagt meine helfen
deine mitteln versorgt na ja da war ich
gut
da nehme ich erzähle ich nicht an den
mir die kamera ausland gedacht
auf jeden fall fangen wir an wir haben
zwar das fleisch übrigens haltungsform
54 ist bio 5 ist 5 ist million 1 5 ist
bio und 5 ist wenn du sogar noch den
namen des tieres kennst wusste musste
derweil risiko erlebt macht das nein
egal freiland richtig frei land unter
vom land oder im freiland mit dem pass
doch wird höchstens so auf jeden fall
kann schon mal kann es sein dass
irgendwas gegen meinen namen doch egal
und egal wo wir sehen ob ich sie egal wo
ich mit ihm bin
das spricht mich immer darauf an auch
nicht im deutschen pass habe ich mir
schon aufgefallen und wenn 50 menschen
da ist sagt du hast du in deutschland
fast immer weil du weißt du die
antworten weiß ich dass ich kein haar
oder nein
das ist doch wirklich auf jeden fall
aber schon in in mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten doch das musste mal gesagt
werden genau wollte ich gerade sagen
kannst da und zwar ganz einfach du
machst es einfach so und dann kann es
ein bisschen kleiner schneiden weil
kulash das ist ein bisschen zu groß okay
das machst du übrigens ja daran wollen
genau das kind später einmal etwas
fleisch schneiden oder meditiert du das
muss man mit liebe machen und sagen
hochschulstudium so während die das
macht machen das ganz cool ist und zwar
brauche geschichte so werden hier
schneidet man eine schnelle arbeit und
zwar nimmt die champignons beistand ist
ganz ganz wichtig viele machen den
fehler die besseren entschädigung dh die
putzen damit wasser nicht gut weil der
sau auf wasser wind schwach dass ich weg
will
er saugt fällt auf wie ein schwamm und
und wie gesagt und solche champignons
beginnend mit einem feuchten tuch ein
bisschen abwischen
genau jetzt nämlich dass gerade so
machen wie ich glaube ich dir ein
sie ist das bin ich das mach ich habe
die jungs ein viertel
[Musik]
so wusste ich nur einig werden dass
geringer miteinander also passt ist er
wusste eigentlich das was die türkei
panzerung große schrift was gedacht also
schon mal gesehen habe
[Gelächter]
aber wollen wir auf jeden fall würde der
typische panzer der hat ja da hat er
drei vorwärtsgänge also es schnell sehr
schnell supermacht
[Gelächter]
so haben wir abschneiden entscheiden
aber halt nicht so gut nicht zu können
wir nicht ins kuvert die nicht so sind
genau auf dieses gut man kann halt
verschiedene brust nehmen als remote mit
bekommt man kann auch zum kakao oder man
kann auch eine thüringer mussten nehmen
oder wie auch immer der in kens
thüringen ist ganz getan für ihre würste
für bratwurst ja genau
man kann zwar werden mac oder schreiben
machen doch kann ich machen was ich habe
es nur ausgedacht
wir führen würde dass da alle vier jahre
alle tiere nicht gut so jetzt habe ich
die chance gewartet hast du auch machen
kannst du die nachts um die wurst
geschnitten hast du kannst die karten
schneiden kannst die würfel ok hat schon
mal karten gewürfelt
da gibt's auch ein gerät dafür wird
lässt sich das labor gefunden habe er
gerät in der küche war die karotten auch
ganz wichtig als das spiel eigentlich
hiervon abschneiden ein bisschen hiervon
absteigen und gar nicht mit der schale
in der schale steckt übrigens mal
gedanken machen
auf jeden fall macht dass manche sagen
ja ich möchte mir gar nicht an sich
so genau
sie ist intelligent ist anstatt ein
würstchen zu nehmen verstehe ich hier
das war das erste mal wo ich merke der
typ denkt doch mit deshalb von dieser
okay ein geschenk der stadt vor allem
eines sein so auf jeden fall
es kommt ganz schnell wieder ändern so
während mini schmerz ist im anflug
okay wer hier die würstchen schneidet
und die karotten in würfel macht man
sich in die zwiebel rand weil es wichtig
über das triebisch einfach du musst
samir sich schnell sein dass es nicht
anfängt zu weinen und da der krimi hat
nicht gerade der schnellste ist mache
ich lieber die zwiebel roche auch wenn
bio ziemlich immer daran denken zwiebeln
maschinen ich denke dass auch cool
schmecken würde hier
wobei er ein ich muss ihr könnt ihr zum
beispiel rote zwiebel denen aber rote
zwiebel schmecken ehrung musste studios
wer bekommt von rochow von rot-weiss
wahlstedt die machst du auch hier in
indien hin rhein bietet in die klein
schneiden noch ja eher klein schneiden
im wirbel ja muss jetzt nicht würfel
seien also nicht so klein muss nicht
sein könnte ein bisschen bis fester sein
kann ist eine geometrisch oder kannst du
überhaupt sagen dass du überhaupt nicht
in der schule gefehlt
[Musik]
also zusammengeschnitten also geschieht
meine ganz coole geschichte jetzt gleich
viel schneller als in den videos
schneidet viertel unter halbieren je
nachdem wir jetzt machen wollte klar
statt so auch rein
die nicht immer einfache option auch
heimwerken
so und jetzt macht sie zwei mal zwei mal
noch mal kommen noch mal machen ja was
jetzt zweimal russland hier war ja ich
habe in zwei schritten das heißt 22 noch
mal 22 nochmal sei zwar gut oder noch
mal 123 kennenlernen mit ziehen lassen
kennst du dich gut aus
auf jeden fall jetzt lassen wir gerade
hier drin
aber gerade das messer raus sagt jetzt
die kartoffeln die tust du auch noch
optionen genau in die stückchen kannst
du machen oder was da auch machen kannst
auch ein cooler job ist es wieder müssen
wir drei machen sagt sie ist das wie
schnell es geht bis du das gemacht hat
hier wollen wir nicht gemerkt hat was
zerstört weißt du hast du hast wenn das
ding ziehe ich das hin was rauskommt ist
genau das aber sagt für vegetarier ist
ich habe das von bonn gehört kann es
sein dass seine vorfahren in barcelona
an diesem an diesem turm an diesem
gauditurnier gearbeitet haben hat er
gedauert 300 jahre ist die fähig war
wie sie wissen bin ich sehr gespannt war
ein ganz kann die beide aus indien
ja das war gaudi es warten dingen an
architekt mannes soll das meist ein
brand keinen zu der professor lesch ja
recht kostenlos ja ja du bist ja noch du
bist ja noch schlimmer wie der professor
es ist glück ist alles ja es hat mich
verblüfft dass über jahre angeeignet
so ich hatte ja geklappt geklaut so
langsam erhitzen
so langsam erhitzen jetzt brauche ich
hier nichts raus und durch schon ok
damit einer hand ok ok sondern immer ein
kochlöffel dankeschön und dann habe ich
es gesehen hatte es gesehen
daraus müssen wir zwei dinge auftreten
nein in las vegas siegfried unruh und
nein die uhr an der türkische ein
armband auf jeden fall da warten wir
gerade ein bisschen genau ein topf
niemals ohne öl das gar nicht auf 5
auch ist so durften die du hast du die
dinger eingeschaltet aber nix läuft
merkt schon so
das haben wir alles ganz folgendes genau
die gleichen schlüssel
wir müssen nicht immer alles abspielen
warum wir und männer sind ja ja so ist
das auch ja gut ich bin ein mann ich
möchte nochmals zurück sollen dinge habe
ich habe den hörgeräten ein bisschen sie
ganz deutschland ist aber das kommt von
wenn ihr das olivenöl ist die zeigt man
muss mir grad zogen bis zum hals so
kranz deswegen ja und zwar das auch
probieren
das ist folge durch es geht nichts
durchsichtig bekommst am morgen in den
spiegel schaut was auch jetzt mal
ehrlich kratzt ist ein bisschen halt so
ein bisschen netzwerkes
also kannst gar nicht im heizungs osten
weil ich hatte die oliven in meinen
füßen ausgepresst wann hast du jetzt
einfach mal was kaputt zu reden denke
ich einfach ich rede mit einer wand ein
echtes problem ich erzähle ich weiß
jedes feld auf der anderen seite fahren
soll jetzt zumal das fleisch hier rein
kurz ankara kann trotz doppelt so oft
mit hochgenau kurz hoch nicht scharf
anbraten also spannbreite stacheldraht
größte raum entstehen ich kann es euch
ganz genau sagen
137 das ist die reaktion 137 maria
reaktion
ziemlich voll geblendet der lichtpunkt
exportwerten ich habe voll die skills
braucht inzwischen das gehalt also bis
am privaten weiter
wer jetzt noch kurz scharf anbraten so
jetzt noch eine frage manchmal auch nur
des musters weißt du warum ihren läuft
wenn ich sage nur eine chance also nicht
warum hier lockt fällig
nein jetzt überlegen warum ich hier noch
weniger material nein auch nicht damit
ihr durch guten könnt wie blöd kann man
eigentlich sein sagt ja auch grund für
das tolle an der ganzen geschichte die
klinge hatte diese wifi oder ist die
türkische bevor eingeschmissen auf jeden
fall da geht's merkel die sich die wie
viel anbrennen
das ist wieso es darum macht man ja
sagen sagen aber wir haben jetzt nicht
mal ja ja ja ja ja ja habe ja jetzt
richtig
obwohl obwohl ich jetzt noch keine rost
aroma zweikampf mit rosberg ja genau
obwohl ich noch keine rösler im
erzeugungsmix wie die dinge gern als
menschen angerichtet
ja und das ist gehen ja da was zu halten
und sogar aus österreich zahlen
jetzt reicht es vollkommen glaub mir
jetzt selber gerade isst fleisch
jetzt ist es raus los
perfekt wird so starke oberarme ist
aufgefallen wahnsinn so folgendes
perfekt ist so schlupp linie genau wie
genau was auch nichts verschwenden das
ist aber nicht warum ich hab' ich putze
ich meine hände die trasse des todes so
ging jetzt mal folgendes zwiebeln
anbraten mit dem knoblauch so die
zwiebel nicht anbrennen wirklich nicht
anders ist ein riesenfehler was du immer
machst anbrennen weil er mehr als bitter
das heißt die zylinder classic schön
glasig werden und jetzt kommt der trick
dabei jetzt noch tomatenmark dreifach
konzentriert rein und es gibt für alles
recht einfach wahnsinnig sagt das haben
wir tomatenmark reingemacht ist schon
wahnsinn so okay so als nächstes
versuchen noch ein bisschen genau ist
die reihenfolge jetzt nicht mehr wichtig
nur zu letztes ding so genau
kartoffeln reis sowie kann doch nicht
anbrennen so perfekt
als nächstes nehmen wir unser wasser es
ist uns war ganz ganz tolles rezept
funktion nur mit dem guten alten
wiesentaler wasser aus der menge
ohne diesen tag war für das wasser
brauchen damit die karte genau zum garen
damit die kartoffeln nach advanced
folgendes tomaten was fällt dir hier ein
weitermachen können wir noch vierteln
wenn man so will die veranstaltung nein
sondern aus der dose alles richtig ist
der einzige mensch der nummer tomaten
aus der dose viertel würden die
verteilen sich dieses gleich als würdest
du einfach cola durch ein haarsieb
machen damit ihr die farbe braun raus
klar mein gott wir danken kann mal sein
das gibt's doch nicht das versuche ich
auf jeden fall hier nimmer tomaten auch
nicht genau aber es gibt eine richtige
zu pressen coole ein tüv ist ein tropfen
dann hast du ein holziger leitung wobei
man holz fertigen wir immer in den wald
wo hast du im wald jemals karotten
gefunden
auf jeden fall du hast du aber was weiß
ich schon mal hast du mein kumpel mal
gesagt wenn man sich die heutigen bald
machen
deswegen heißt es im holzfäller wo das
ist schon mal hast du schon mal macht
schon mal im wald und bis durch den wald
gelaufen da guckst du den baum angesagt
auch mal einen brief an karotten oder
durch den hochwald und plötzlich seine
komischen dritte mit dem baltikum hat er
war damals abgehauen bayern ja super 6
wurde die kuh alles wann wer das war
keine cook das war es waren ein problem
werden nein das machen können sogar eine
toilette und kenntnis noch problembär
ich sag nur sieg und stoiber wie macht
markus thorandt dieses buch hat kann man
ja an gewürzen macht sich je nach
geschmack die laubblätter lass mich das
lieber machen durchschnitt keinen spaß
machen alle fragen ja alles rein genau
nachher kann man mal probieren wir
können ein bisschen mehr rein machen
beim kreuz können wir aufpassen kann ist
ja geschmackssache
also alles rein sieht toll aus
so wie gesagt nachher dienste sagen
spitze angespielt etwas dicker geworden
haben dieses wasser wir haben das
aufgesogen deswegen das ist genau das
dann hast du auch schon mal im film
button
auch das hoch dass auf jeden fall genau
was genau ich mache jetzt mal ein
bisschen da ist genau bisschen mehr eine
höhere hitze wir haben wir haben stufe
eins bis zehn kids momentan bei 8 genau
und jetzt ist ganz ganz wichtig vor sich
hin köcheln lassen so ungefähr 10
minuten und nach diesen zehn minuten
mache ich das mache ich das ulla schmidt
rein so jetzt hat jetzt habe ich auf
stufe acht gemacht also wir haben wir
haben zehn stufen und müssen jetzt schon
48 sorgt das ist mal richtig heiß war
jetzt nehme ich das fleisch alles
richtig genial mit dem derby wahnsinn
also
und eigentlich voll die sich ja so ein
bisschen durchmischen
da ist definitiv zu wenig flüssigkeit
bin da ist nicht zu wenig flüssigkeit
trainer natürlich ging es muss doch
alles jahren ging ich weiß es doch aber
das gab jetzt glaubt mir
und zwar beispielsweise folgendes du
hättest recht wenn es ein normaler topf
wäre
wir haben in gusseisen topf und
gusseisen treter
es ist hier ein und jetzt kann keine
flüssigkeit mehr entweichen ok gebeutelt
so da drehte ich es wie in einer sauna
der top hat übrigens fünfeinhalb liter
ohne schwarze also das heißt wenn er das
rezept macht dann müsste so einen topf
nehmen mit fünfeinhalb bis sechs liter
an zu großen druck und so lassen wir
sagen wir eineinhalb bis zwei stunden so
richtig cool schmoren
was wir auch machen könnt wenn ihr mann
ihr bock habt ihr könnt zum beispiel
auch den den topf können jetzt zum
beispiel einfach in den in den backofen
reinmachen schön bei 160 170 grad mal
auch zwei stunden drin lassen es ist
auch möglich
also man hat mich an machen möchte im
backofen was wir auch machen könnt ist
wenn ihr so ein kugelgrill hab ihnen
einfach ein kugelgrill könnt den kopf
einfach die gusseisernen topf auf den
kreisstellen kultur zu machen oder auch
zwei drei stunden
schönkirchen das verbrennen dann
passiert gar nichts bin ich alles malen
nein es ist ja das ist immer an ihre
gusseisen und warum habe ich das gemacht
weil ich
nachgedacht haben und das ist genau das
was dich der menschen was irgendwann ein
entscheid den menschen mit stil der mend
menschen immer vorausschauend das tier
denkt immer an das jetzt aus ihren titel
du bist ja so ist das manchmal denke ich
liebe kinder wer ist hier anschaut nimmt
es nicht mal das ist ganz was man machen
müsse natürlich sehr sehr gute freunde
oder gelogen aber egal nimmt es endlich
mal das ganze was nicht zueinander sagen
wir mögen uns eigentlich und eineinhalb
stunden später
[Musik]
auf jeden fall jetzt überfällig wir
haben das jetzt ungefähr zwei stunden
wirklich auf dem herd gehabt wie gesagt
ich könnte es auch einen grill machen
und im backofen er das möchte
das geht mit dem großen topf immer so
jetzt wenn man mal probieren müssen
durchführen und ihr merkt eigentlich
also es kommt darauf an wie groß die das
fleisch geschnitten wie große die
kartoffeln geschnitten haben wenn ihr
merkt kartoffeln durch 100 prozent in
das fleisch muss richtig zeit sein das
heißt wenn es nicht solche tat ich
einfach noch ein bisschen länger köchelt
wirklich aufs fleisch ja du hast ja
nicht aufs fleisch geguckt deswegen hast
du auch so viel so auf jeden fall
natürlich an den test es wird mir ja
keine kosten und mühen sparen und
scheuen tschuldigung sparen sparen
sparen ja ja ja schon und haben
natürlich auch grass eingeladen der
gerade hier bei uns war und zwar ist der
vater habe ich aber ist journalist ist
in einer aber bei einer tageszeitung
kommt auch find ich ja genau spricht ein
bisschen deutsch
aber ein gutes englisch we can speak
english darf ich mich übergeben mein
gott warum universe in winnipeg in
kanada will ich selber baut das
instrument das ist türkisch auch von
türkisch englisch was heißt ein förster
auf englisch lumberjack richterpult vom
holzfäller jagger
englisch ist sie zwar gerne kann
entsprechend small intelligent ja danke
sie hatten sich gemerkt wir wollen ja ok
der anschluss ist man nicht so viel du
hast mit mc grath hauptschule neunte
klasse englisch leistungskurs lange sehr
schön weil wir gerade die schuld der cmx
aber auch türkisch and german food
türkisches salalah wie kann ich sagen
ist alles auch türkisch sagt dass es
nicht verstehst
[Gelächter]
ja er hat gesagt die medistar guckt also
das fleisch ist schon gut gekocht nein
nicht der typ neben mir der riecht ein
bisschen komisch sagt er will ich nicht
mehr wiedersehen
ja ok auf jeden fall hatten es echt spaß
gemacht mit euch zusammen zu kochen mit
war mir eine ehre mit ihr vater wirst du
hier machst
wir machen auch jack coleman collins
zeitungsbericht du darfst türkisch
hoheitsgebiet nicht mehr betreten jetzt
nach diesem video
warum hast du denn präsidenten bestätigt
ich sage ja auch wer macht's gut macht's
besser auf die auffahrt ich ich muss
erstmal abschnitt gebieten muss man es
sagen du bist nicht so dumm wie du
aussiehst dass das dann zu ruhig mit
also das gesund bist du blöd ist nur
meldung im wald leben war der körper
bleibt raum zurück
[Gelächter]
[Musik]